Whether you're a lifelong horror hound or
a new convert to the joys of the genre, it's
a good time to be a horror fan.
Recent years have had something for everyone,
and 2019 is showing no sign of letting us
down yet.
Here are the best horror films of the year
so far.
Midsommar follows Dani, a young girl tagging
along with her boyfriend and his friends to
a remote Swedish village as it prepares for
a rare midsummer festival.
As you might expect, things escalate from
there.
Midsommar isn't just horrifying — while
there are some standard horror elements thrown
in, the bulk of what makes the movie frightening
is also what it has in common with Hereditary.
It's about guilt and grief and loss, and the
entire film feels raw and unnerving.
This tale of a family encountering their own
crazed, murderous doubles is even more layered
and complex in its themes than Jordan Peele's
previous Get Out, and decidedly more ambitious.
It's intense, deeply original, and scary as
heck.
Us proves that Jordan Peele's position as
one of the most important creative voices
of his generation is secure.
Plus, the movie also proves definitively that
Lupita Nyong'o is one of the greatest actors
currently working.
"The girl had a second child, a boy this time.
They had to cut her open and take him from
her belly."
The original Happy Death Day finds a college
student getting murdered by a masked killer
again and again, forced to relive her birthday
until she can figure out how to break the
time loop.
2019's sequel, Happy Death Day 2U moves the
story just one day into the future and deeper
into science fiction.
The film is packed with quantum reactors,
alternate timelines, and colliding doppelgangers
twisting in all kinds of directions, including
back into the original film.
It's a bigger, better, wilder film than the
original.
Reboots can be tricky.
Follow too closely to the original, and there's
a good chance a film will be labeled as lazy.
Go too far outside the lines, you'll lose
the nostalgia appeal.
2019's Child's Play manges to walk that fine
line, giving a 1980s horror story about a
possessed doll an internet-era update that
plays on the ridiculousness of its premise.
Yes, Child's Play is going to be about what
you'd expect to see from a killer doll film.
But it also seems to have an understanding
of its own limitations and doesn't try to
project some deeper meaning.
It's an hour and a half of gory horror, wrapped
up in a bow of '80s nostalgia.
Velvet Buzzsaw finds director Dan Gilroy turning
a satirical lens on the pretentious culture
of fine art.
Jake Gyllenhaal and Rene Russo lead an ensemble
cast of characters who come into contact with
the works of a little-known deceased painter.
The paintings themselves begin killing off
critics and dealers one by one, putting a
serious crimp in their lucrative dealings
and torrid affairs.
This supernatural, occasionally silly, blood-drenched
commentary on the collision of art and commerce
didn't quite garner the overwhelming praise
that Nightcrawler earned.
Nonetheless, plenty of critics found plenty
to enjoy in this campy horror flick.
"The best work is only enjoyed by a few and
they buy what they're told, so why not join
the party?"
Fresh off Jordan Peele's 2017 horror hit Get
Out, Allison Williams takes another dive into
the genre here as Charlotte, a former musical
prodigy who begins an affair with her school's
current lead cellist, Elizabeth.
While it's clear from the opening credits
of The Perfection that Charlotte doesn't have
the purest of intentions, the full extent
of her motivation makes for one hell of a
twisted ride.
To say more would spoil the insane twists
of the film, but trust us when we say that
the film is not for the faint of heart.
The film itself might not be perfect, but
The Perfection definitely feels one of a kind.
Greta is as much about emotional vulnerability
as it is about the horrors of befriending
random strangers in the New York City subway
system.
Chloë Grace Moretz plays Frances, a young
woman new to the city, who's dealing with
her mother's recent death and is in need of
a friend.
Enter Greta, a seemingly kind older woman
who's forgotten her purse on the subway and
could also use a friend.
The pair strike up a relationship and it isn't
nearly as innocent as it first appears to
be.
The wide open spaces of the American frontier
are often romanticized by classic westerns,
but The Wind recognizes the horrific potential
of all that emptiness.
In the film, tough frontierswoman Lizzy is
haunted by that emptiness, personified by
the ever-present wind howling across the plains.
Despite reassurances from her husband, Lizzy
becomes increasingly convinced that some sort
of demonic presence is haunting their homestead.
Is there something supernatural out there,
or is the horror of The Wind nothing more
or less than loneliness itself?
It's a question that will haunt anyone who
goes along for this moody, atmospheric ride.
The Hole in the Ground spins a subtle story
about a woman and her son moving to a village
in the countryside to escape a troubled past.
But there's something disturbing about their
new home — namely, the enormous sinkhole
in the nearby woods.
The atmosphere and metaphors of The Hole in
the Ground are far better experienced than
described, but we'll just say that you won't
be disappointed when you dive in to check
them out for yourself.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.